we had an opportunity uh present itself
to buy a home from a family friend at a
pretty well discounted price we knew
that it was too much house for us it's a
4200 sare ft house
$315,000 is what we paid for it um
firsttime home buyer so we didn't have
any money to put down 0% Downs that we
got barely making it living paycheck to
paycheck um struggling our marriage was
struggling we just decided we can't do
this anymore if if we want this to work
sold the house in seven days for
$415,000 so $100,000 more than we gave
for it I bought my wife a car what are
you smoking that you go buy a $37,000
car after you just sold a house because
you couldn't breathe man when I went
broke Logan I was your age and I had to
sit down and do an autopsy a CSI on Dave
and I looked at all the stupid butt
stuff Dave was doing and had to go if
you want to live like this you can keep
doing the stupid butt stuff